well Michael you've talked about the
entire six-stage plot structure you've
touched on each point briefly and I know
we went into depth on stage 1 and stage
2 can we go further into depth on stage
3 which is progress of the character
sure once the character has formulated
their outer motivation that necessary
visible goal that's going to lead us all
the way to the climax stage 3 this way
they start pursuing it they formulate a
plan and they start going after that
goal and that's where they start
encountering more and more of the
conflict more and more of the obstacles
standing in their way either obstacles
that are coming from the outside world
this such as forces of nature if it's
say an avalanche in a movie like that or
a fire or a disease or an alien invasion
which is kind of like a force of nature
or from other characters if it's a
thriller and it's a bad guy you know
coming after our hero or something like
that but those obstacles are going to
start appearing they're going to have to
avoid them or overcome them or whatever
but their plan seems to be working well
that's why I call it progress but on the
inner journey level something else
happens that's critical because remember
I talked about a character's identity
this false persona that they wear to
keep them emotionally safe to keep them
from taking too much emotional risk and
where they can hide the thing that
frightens them most well because the
rule is they can't achieve the visible
goal without stepping into their essence
and out of that persona they're going to
have to drop the armor in order to make
progress toward that goal
the problem with dropping the armor is
it's terrifying emotionally so take for
example in hitch as he starts falling
for the AVA Mendez character it's very
scary for him because his armor is I
don't really fall in love myself that's
not for me I'm just a one-night stand
kind of guy I help other guys fall in
love so the more vulnerable he needs to
get in order to win her love the scarier
it's going to be for him so what will
happen in this stage is the hero will
vacillate back and forth between
identity in essence they'll open up and
take courageous steps toward their goal
but then they will in return retreat
because it'll get too scary emotionally
especially if you're dealing with the
inner journey and it's like a love story
romantic comedy or something where there
really needs to be a deep transformation
if you take Good Will Hunting as an
example his goal is to win the love of
Skylar Good Will Hunting is basically
strictly a love story that's really what
it is is he going to live win the love
of mini driver of the mini driver
character well as he starts dating her
they start getting close he gets scared
and then he backs off and when he's
talking to Shawn the Robin Williams
character Shawn at one point says well
what about that girl you were dating and
he said oh no you know how it is to go
on a second date you know then they
don't really live up to what you
expected them to be and then Shauna
returns says maybe what you're afraid of
is you won't live up to what she expects
you to be because what Shawn is there
for is to keep pointing out the
emotional fear that Will Hunting carries
around because of his abuse abuse path
so we see us he's dating Skylar he gets
closer to her and then he doesn't talk
to her and you'll get closer and then
they'll manufacture an argument and it's
back and forth back and forth
vacillating between identity and essence
so hobbling along in that way the
character is getting closer and closer
until the character the hero reaches the
point of no return
that's the third key turning point and
that's the midpoint of the movie that
that means that something happens at
that moment that is going to demand of
the character or it's going to lead the
hero to make a much bigger commitment to
the goal in love stories or romantic
comedies it is almost always the point
where the character goes to bed with the
love interest for the first time kisses
for the first time as in wedding
crashers
declares I love you for the first time
maybe
and has the first official date in hitch
it's interesting because they actually
spend the night together for the first
time even though there's no sex involved
but it's when the two of them open up
more than they ever have about their
past and about what their emotional
fears are and they get closer and now
after crossing that point of no-return
the hero moves into stage four what I
call complications and higher stakes and
what happens there on the outer journey
level is the obstacles are gonna get
bigger and bigger it's almost like God
is saying or the writer who is God over
these characters is saying okay I think
it's great you made this full commitment
to your goal now let's put it to the
test and so the obstacles will start
coming faster closer together get bigger
and bigger and this is key for someone
writing a screenplay what needs to
happen is the outside world needs to
start closing in on your hero so the
rival boyfriend might show up or if it's
a thriller it might be that the midpoint
is when the villain discovers that the
hero is on to him and now he's going to
the pursuer the pursuit is going to
become the pursuer and he'll start
coming after the hero and she'll be in
danger because she really realizes she
is coming after him so the outside world
is going to come closing and in Titanic
the outside world is the iceberg and the
sinking ship it's that's the test she's
up against can she still maintain her
love for Jack and and her journey toward
living a fully passionate life in the
face of the ship sinking and almost
certain death so it's going to get
tougher and tougher and tougher for that
character until your hero reaches the
the fourth key turning point the three
quarter mark of your script or your
movie the end of Act two what I call the
major setback which is when everything
basically goes to
you